>> Not only can we use measures of center to make decisions, but we can also use
them for comparisons. Take, for example, Facebook friends. How many Facebook
friends do you have? Click the link at the poll that's titled, How many Facebook
friends do you have? If you don't have Facebook, enter 0 for your number of
friends. After this, you can click the Facebook friends results link and compare
yourself to others. According to an article on Mashable, the average Facebook
user has 229 friends. 22% of these friends are from high school, 12% are
co-workers, and 9% from college. In 2008, the average Facebook user was 33 years
old. But in 2010, the average user was 38 years old. And one more fun fact, 52%
of facebook users visit Facebook daily. So, these are a lot of averages
concerning Facebook usage. If you want to compare yourself to the average more,
Zeebly.com slash socialme has some really fun statistics. They'll prepare a
personalized report that analyzes your Facebook usage. So, if you haven't
already, enter the number of Facebook friends you have by clicking the link at
the right. We're going to analyze this data later.